Hello everybody my name is Markiplier!
and welcome back out oxygen not included!
Now, I know in the last episode I was a
little cataclysmic about all this.
I was desperate I was feeling past
mystic about their chances of survival
but I realized that I can't give up on
my family and I know they're not my real
family but in this game they might
be clones they might be copies they're
duplicates but their lives are in my
hands and if I have to take
responsibility for this I will. So I'm
gonna make sure that they survive and I
have a plan to do it so first off the
main problem is oxygen and carbon
dioxide. They're using too much oxygen,
they're making too much carbon dioxide.
It's poisoning everything down here and
I don't have the means to purify that
just yet that is in advanced filtration
and I don't know. There's a few other research
categories that I need to be able to
filter out carbon dioxide with an air
scrubber and that uses a filtration
medium such as sand and i'm going to get that but for the immediate future
we also need algae and the algae is
actually here there's algae down here
there's algae up here there's a lot of
algae still in this area that can scrub
carbon dioxide to bias time until we get
there but we need to do a lot of stuff so
it requires a great overhaul of
everything that we got to do and I know
everyone is stressed to the maximum
there's only a few people that are not
stressed so we just need to start over
but right here. So the first stage of the
plan is to create tiles around here.
Start the room from the very base around
the portal which already has decoration
to it so that people will feel less
stressed when they're around the portal
and then keep these here but i'm
actually going to put these at a low
priority compared to everything else
that we're going to do, I'm gonna
actually put those down at last priority
i'm not going to remove them because
eventually I do want those there but not
yet i'm also going to um cancel this
cancel this dig order so that guy doesn't
have to hold his breath and then like
die down there and then we're going
to build out tile right here along this
wait hang on- Let me just- I gotta to play it for
a second and then-
there we go so we're gonna build tile
all the way from there to there and put
that a high priority because what that's
going to do is it's going to dig out the
algae that is there and then HOPEFULLY,
they're going to be able to use that
algae to be able to do uhh whatever they
need to do you, like get these running
which which are still running so there
is some air scrubber happening but the
only problem is there's a lot of other
things that don't *sigh* don't have what they
need but we need to research advanced
filtration. I AM NOT going to give up on
these people because these people
literally are my family and so when they
build these tiles they're actually going
to remove all the rock that's in the way
first.
They're going to get the algae that is
down there, just like that
and then they're able to collect it and then they'll build on top of it, so these things
aren't going to be destroyed
I will eventually remove that outhouse
and put it over in the compost I don't
know where they're putting anything else
there but these algae terrariums are
eventually working and this guy's not
doing well. So what we need is we need
clean water, we need plumbing, we need a
shower, we need good beds, we need massage
tables ,we need things for everybody to
do, and also we need to get rid of this
because this is not doing anybody any
good
so once that's done we have the basis
for a room and then we need to destroy
this and this- this doesn't make any sense
being there we need to start uhh we need to
start digging through this algae here, we
need to collect
this algae here.... let's see- can you build tile over
that? I don't think so but either way
we're going to build tiles there we're
going to make this make more sense that
the very base of it. We do need to
eventually need like scrubbers down
there so,
I'm thinking algae terrarium should go
down there too just because... just because
it's not going well for us- WELP making a
mess someone just shit their pants
I'm sorry Meep! I'M SORRY! Oh god!
You're shitting right into the water
hole
oh sorry... that's my fault I shouldn't
yell at you Meep! I'm sorry you're good
kid
awh he's doing it again! Oh boi alright,
at least that's getting done so in here
is contaminated water admittedly and I'd
like to get that mopped up but I just
don't know where that's gonna mop too, *sigh* so
it's a daunting task but I'm up to the
challenge
oh yes, I am. So what I am going to make here- what
I'm doing is, this is gas-permeable
tile, so what that's going to do- I'm not
going to put that there, I'm going to put
that right- hang on I gotta go to make sure
the outsides are lined with um, build tile- but straight up and down
throughout this whole place I want there
to be gas-permeable tiles so the oxygen
can flow up and down readily. So this is
all going to go eventually, all this is
going to be destroyed in the future and
like obviously that's not ideal
but it is what it is.
So what we also need here is we probably
need *sigh* we need some sort of power
I guess we could put that there, I guess that's a good place as any
but we do need oxygen like an
algae deoxidizer we do need an algae
terrarium here. Probably there will be an
okay place for it and then we're going
to need power, manual generator already
hooked up the power and then we'll just
um... hook that up to a tiny battery
don't really need a big one, connect those
across, connect those across and put these
at a high priority because we're going
to need oxygen unless we're going to close it off
umm anywhere lucky- AND LET'S WELCOME A
NEW MEMBER OF THE FAMILY! I know it's probably
irresponsible to have people here.
Uh scaredy-cat can't perform combat that's
probably okay, greasemonkey tinkering is
good
Twinkletoes, good athleticism, twinkle
toes, and iron gut, loud sleeper... Oh bOi *sigh*
i'm gonna go with Suki come on Suki
during I know it's a bad place right now
but hopefully pick something the
experiments going to be a nice place for
you to live I don't know if it's gonna
be now but it's gonna be nice someday
boy for them down here eventually I'm
going to dig down into the water because
we are running low on water here and
eventually what I'll have to do with i
will have to make a water filtration
system to get the contaminated water to
be to a point where people can actually
use it and I know once again that
there's a way to turn water into oxygen
i do know that and we will get there
eventually but for now this is the best
we got what we got to deal with so let's
just let people three people hopefully
not too much longer for the advanced
filtration to kick in
they'll be very thing will get that
we're going to hurry up i know it's not
ideal to hurry up in this point i want
to take us home
I want to pay very close attention to
everything going on here but I'm for bad
everybody time for bed
we have enough beds for everybody all
right we're full house up natsuki I'm
sorry Sookie just the way it goes
sometimes I apologize I apologize
I'm sorry I'm sorry to everybody sorry
to everybody they can't breathe down
here we got people lashing out but it's
okay we've got food it's shit food i
know it's shit food we got food we've
got something how to feed up almost shit
not that batters come on Lenny cock
damn it Lenny I know you gotta do but we
gotta live here we're going to deal with
this
we're going to do what we can let me
we're going to try we've got a household
of 10 and if everybody keeps flashing
out they're not going to have anything
nice
now come on someone put someone put
algae in this thing right I gotta
prioritize this the ladies dig police
we gotta get at least some algae out of
here we don't have a lot left
eventually what I have to do is I have
to what I'll do is off clothes off with
an airlock the slime area and these
things these things actually produce a
steady stream of slime and I shouldn't
have killed it because I need that
because you can turn climb into algae
but also like slime can be like slime
continuously produces contaminated
oxygen it's not good but it's still
oxygen nonetheless
so when you have oxygen even if it's
contaminated you can purify the oxygen
through advanced filtration by using uh
i believe it was maybe I was wrong maybe
I was wrong maybe you can't turn
contaminated oxygen because you can
filter it out but that doesn't mean that
it's going to pump out good oxygen
because i'm pretty sure yeah yeah it
doesn't do anything it doesn't know it
doesn't change it out
yeesh least we're getting oxygen in here
which is good and then when the algae
all boy did someone to shit their pants
again boy
but this is starting to take shape it's
not a hundred percent perfect and it
won't be for a while at least it's
starting to take shape so when this goes
up we're gonna have another room here we
need to build a ladder like straight
down to the water because they can use
it from the they can use it from the
tile there they can use it from the
latter i believe oh well as we got
mealworms
ok time for sleep you guys go beddy-bye
I know Sookie you don't have a bed but
you doing alright spooky Fugees doing ok
I know Sookie like probably walked into
this and not very happy about what's
going on here but we still have oxygen
in here we just don't have a lot of we
don't have a lot of itself
these oxygen things they consume an
absurd amount of algae like there's this
isn't enough algae in this entire area
to be able to sustain it but there's
oodles of flying there's just took this
way too much lime because if i were to
compare like the algae to the slime the
slime it's just non-stop and these
things just constantly produce lime
alright okay good you doing that stuff
that's good we still got contaminated
water there i know that's not ideal home
and we got a lot of it they've been
shitting their pants non-stop over there
right but it looks like we're almost
there on the research front gus was
going for it just gonna get us the last
bit of research will be able to scrub
carbon dioxide out which is good because
then we won't have to rely entirely on
the algae to get rid of carbon dioxide
because if we run out of algae and we
can't scrub the carbon dioxide then we
would die anyway from suffocation
but for now we're gonna be okay don't
hit match the one thing you couldn't
break now Joe Diaz fix it
I'm a long repair to all right it's fine
we got the research we got what we
needed
now we just worried about combustion so
that we got a lot of coal i'm pretty
sure around the place
yeah kool so we can make energy from
that way people don't have to run as
much but i bet that produces pollution
or something so I'm gonna make a bold
move here but we gotta make bold moves
if we're going to be able to do anything
in life we gotta get rid of all this
shit I know destroying that thing is
going to be a problem because it's just
you all the stuff inside but we gotta do
you deconstruct all this so that we can
construct all of this and then hopefully
will move through be able to build a new
room here very quickly
we'll get there for getting this I want
this side I want this side on the right
here to be ladder on the outside the
climbing the bisbee interior navigation
I probably shouldn't have that there
that should probably outside who let me
just yeah that's that's probably not a
good idea to have that there then cancel
that and destroy that and then build an
airlock there
alright cool build an airlock their file
up there its way
yeah the kid can't reach it
missing Foundation well obviously
missing Foundation at least they're
getting to melody out of that so that's
good i know these guys now I don't have
beds again and it's even more stressful
than it was before but hey you know what
I'm doing the best I can
is trying to live life helping people
yeah there's a bad night could not
everyone out of the bed
natsuki anymore sorry maybe that's nice
i did this big play with the
uncomfortable space prison so I don't
think that you guys should expect too
much out of it
yeah okay Wendy construct that gas
permeable wormhole always always shit
that was quite the vomiting okay so what
we have got to get it goes I get it I
get it I get it I get it
ok so we now need to make a carbon
dioxide scrubber and it's got to be on
the bottom we have we have one algae
terrarium down here and it's not going
to be enough to get rid of all the
carbon dioxide because carbon dioxide
seems to fall comparative to anything
else is here i'm gonna put the
destruction order to use that boys can
destroy this construct you can truck and
then in its place we're going to put
something else we've got
we don't have a lot of food actually
holy shit we are low on food when do we
get that low on food
I don't know when we got that low on
food but ok we're gonna make food
production over here because apparently
i don't have the means to do anything
else and also carbon dioxide is being
scrubbed from here already so we're
going to have an a2 these powering one
big battery and then we're going to just
have uh we could do micro pressures too
much bars and then cooking stations to
make them into something more manageable
and then refrigerators to try to even it
all out
I don't know that's gonna be ideal but
maybe we only have on refrigerator I'm
not entirely sure about that but then we
need to connect all with power to do
with you look okay so that should be ok
right
and then since food is the priority
cottage guys so much to survive we need
to do that and then it's just one oxygen
and I know the alligator areas should be
able to feel that small room
I mean if it's a relatively small room
so I don't imagine that's gonna take
much more
ok that gas permeable tile is down there
that's good for people can get in there
that's good
ok alright good good good good good
that's going well it's not going great
we need to mop up this shit eventually
because that's just disgusting arm we
can make this one the lavatory know we
need to make the laboratory area like a
lower chamber can make visit for now
we've got algae terrarium it's not fun
and I i would like to make like good
plumbing you know but I'm thinking
thinking just outhouses for now down
here and then the compost compost that
over there I guess
take this one out make these relatively
high priority group so i can get rid of
that I can get rid of these and make the
living area more livable you know what I
mean he's being kind discussing here huh
it's shaping up it's shaping it's
shaping into something i don't know what
but it's shaping I may be totally wrong
about all my things i want to do here
but it's it's going to be something
going to be a whole lot of something
whoa new member of the family oh boy you
all over the place
Oh bad traits on you okay Dan you're
going to go for it ok so those are good
down there so now i can deconstruct this
and the compost here and get that the
Frick out of here
I know all of mind at all if I know I
know all of its no good i know i'm i'm
well aware of that
I know but anyways i got this underway
broken you broke the one that taught him
okay so we need so these are got to be
like at least six above normal priority
but not like you hi
oh there's so much stress i know there's
so much stress I'm well aware of that
fact
sheesh you got damn it they're all
broken freaking dick
alright time for bad i thank god they're
not going to be able to breathe there
they're going to be able to breathe very
badly
ok man i know i know i know i know the
oxygen situation is pretty dire oh boy
why are you stressed vomiting everyone
here is stretched vomiting oh boy oh boy
ok but but but but even though
absolutely every surface is covered in
vomit and if you can ship and even
though everyone is very unhappy and
almost everyone is that maximum stress i
think we're going to survive this so I'm
gonna end this episode here it may seem
dire but this is actually going better
than I thought it was going to go
I don't ask me how because honestly i
have no freaking clue i really have no
idea and we're just going to do the best
that we can because otherwise death is
the only to take the only other option
and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna just imagine one day not gonna let
him die
now i'm going to so thank you everybody
so much for watching hope you guys are
enjoying this when they're going to go
to bed in a few beds they have thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
*Markiplier's outro music*